so you know when you're doubled over in
pain and you're wondering is it your
appendix or maybe eight something funny
well when that happens to me I call my
friend Sasha Sasha is a doctor and I say
should I rush to the nearest emergency
room in a panic or am i okay to relax
and just wait it out yes I am that's
annoying friend but in September 2017
friends of mine was suddenly calling me
for my professional opinion and no I'm
not a doctor but they were asking me
questions of life and death so what was
going on in September 2017 well North
Korea was suddenly and scarily all over
the news Kim jong-un had tested missiles
potentially capable of hitting major US
cities and president Trump had responded
with tweets of fire and fury and there
was real concern that tensions would
escalate to a potential war or even
nuclear weapons use so what my friends
were calling and asking was should they
panic were they okay to relax but really
they were asking me a fundamental
question am i safe while I was
reassuring them that no they didn't need
to worry just yet there are any of their
question dawned on me what they hadn't
really thought about is that we've all
been living under a much larger cloud
for decades potentially a mushroom cloud
without giving it much thought now it's
not surprising that friends of mine and
many others like them don't know much
about nuclear weapons I don't think
about them after all the end of the Cold
War the United States and Russia tension
abated
we started dismantling nuclear weapons
and they started to become a relic of
the past generations didn't have to grow
up with the specter of nuclear war
hanging over their heads there are other
reasons people don't like to think about
nuclear weapons it's scary
overwhelming I get it sometimes I wish I
could have chosen a cheerier field to
study perhaps tax law would have been
more uplifting but in addition to that
people have so many other things to
think about in their busy lives and then
much prefer to think about something
over which they feel they have some
semblance of control and they assume
that other people smarter than me on
this topic are working away to keep us
all safe and then there are other
reasons people don't talk about this and
one is because we as nuclear experts
here's a whole lot of convoluted jargon
and terminology to talk about these
issues CVID ICBM jcpoa it's really
inaccessible for a lot of people and in
reality it actually sometimes I think
makes us numb it's what really talking
about here and what we are really
talking about here is the fact that
while we've made dramatic reductions in
the number of nuclear weapons since the
Cold War right now there are almost
15,000 in the world today 15,000 United
States and Russia have over 90% of these
nuclear weapons if you're wondering
these are the countries that have the
rest but they have far fewer ranging in
the sort of 300 ish range and below
adding to this situation is the fact
that we have new technologies that
potentially bring us new challenges
because you imagine one day countries
like ours and others potentially ceding
decisions about a nuclear strike to a
robot based on algorithms and what data
that they use to inform those algorithms
this is pretty terrifying so adding to
this terrorism potential cyberattacks
miscalculation misunderstanding the list
of nuclear nightmares tends to grow
longer by the day and there are a number
of former officials as well as experts
who worry that right now we're in
greater danger that we were in various
points in the Cold War so this is scary
what can we do well thankfully we don't
have to rely on the advice from the
1950s we can take some control and the
way we do that is by starting to ask
some fundamental questions about the
status quo and whether we're happy with
the way it is we need to begin asking
questions of ourselves and our elected
officials and I'd like to share three
with you today the first one it's how
much nuclear risk are you willing to
take or tolerate right now nuclear
policy depends on deterrence theory
developed in the 1950s the idea is that
one country's nuclear weapons prevents
another country from using theirs so
unique me a new cue and we both lose so
in a way there's a stalemate no one uses
their weapons and we're all safe but
this theory has real questions there are
experts who challenge this theory and
wonder doesn't really work this way in
practice it certainly doesn't allow for
mistakes or miscalculations now I don't
know about you but I feel pretty
uncomfortable gambling my future
survival yours and our future
generations on a theory that is
questionable and doesn't allow any room
for mistake makes me even more
uncomfortable to be threatening the
operation of millions of people on the
other side of the earth surely we can do
better for ourselves drawing on our
ingenuity to solve complex problems as
we have in the past after all this is a
man-made human-made I shouldn't say men
because women were involved a human-made
problem we have human solutions that
should be possible so next question who
do you think should make nuclear
decisions right now in this democracy in
the United States one person gets to
decide whether or not to launch a
nuclear strike they don't have to
consult anybody so that's the president
he or she can decide within a very
limited amount of time under great
pressure potentially depending on the
scenario may be based on a
miscalculation or misunderstanding they
can decide the fate of millions of lives
yours mine our communities and they can
do this and launch a nuclear strike
potentially setting in motion the
annihilation of the human race well this
doesn't have to be our reality though
and in fact in a number of other
countries that have nuclear weapons it's
not including countries that are not
democracies we created this system we
can change it and there's actually
movement underway to do so so this leads
me to my third question what are your
elected officials know about nuclear
weapons and what types of decisions are
they likely to take on your behalf
well Congress has a very important role
to play in oversight and interrogating
US nuclear weapons policy they can
decide what to fund what not to fund and
they represent you now unfortunately
since the end of the Cold War we've seen
a
real decline in the level of
understanding on Capitol Hill about
these issues while we are starting to
see some terrific new champions emerge
the reality is that the general lack of
awareness is highly concerning given
that these people need to make
critically important decisions to make
matters worse the political partisanship
that currently grips Washington also
affects this issue this wasn't always
the case though the end of the Cold War
members from both sides of the aisle had
a really good understanding about the
nuclear challenges we were facing and
work together on cooperative programs
they recognized that nuclear risk
reduction was far too important to allow
it to succumb to political partisanship
they created programs such as the
nunn-lugar Cooperative Threat Reduction
program which sought to lock down and
eliminate vulnerable nuclear material in
the former Soviet Union so we need to
return to this era of bipartisanship
mutual problem solving with that's based
on understanding and awareness about the
challenges we face and the real nuclear
dangers and that's where you come in
public pressure is important leaders
need a constituent base to act so create
that's constituent base by asking them
some simple questions ask them what do
you know about nuclear weapons do you
have a nuclear expert on your staff or
if not do you know somebody you could
refer to if you need to make an
important decision start to find out
what they believe and whether it aligns
with your own views and values ask them
how would you choose to spend u.s.
national treasure on a new nuclear arms
race or another national security
priority such as cyber security or
climate change ask them are you willing
to put aside partisanship to address
this existential threat that affects my
survival and your constituents survival
now
people will tell you nuclear policy is
far too difficult to understand and
complex too nuanced for the general
public to understand let alone debate
after all this is national security it
needs to be secrets don't let that put
you off we debate all sorts of issues
that are critically important to our
lives
why should nuclear weapons be any
different we debate healthcare education
environment surely congressional
oversight civic participation that are
such hallmarks of us democracy surely
they apply here after all these are
cases of life and death that we're
talking about and we won't all agree but
whether or not you believe nuclear
weapons keep us safe or that nuclear
weapons are a liability I urge you to
put aside partisan ideological issues
and listen to each other so I'll tell
you now what I didn't have the guts to
tell my friends at the time no you're
not safe not just because of North Korea
but there is something you can do about
it demand that your elected
representatives can give you answers to
your questions and answers that you can
live with and that billions of others
can live with - and if they can't stay
on them until they can and if that
doesn't work find others who are able to
represent your views because by doing so
we can begin to change the answer to the
question am i safe